something
[Music]
great thank you
so again he goes up I follow the uh Yin
face you push it down
and so I yield
[Music]
okay first let's look at the turtle
position
okay he has to get out of that Turtle
so I can't spin that far how far do I
spin when he gets out of the turtle
position I don't know where it'll be
because I can't drop
where he's on his knees
that's how far you can find okay
it's not up to okay
to read Turtle I go for my opinion he
takes his legs out no
you understand
second thing
there is no pin laying on his back
Rocio is not a shoulder lock
no this guy's stronger than me I'm
laying on him
stand up
we'll kill his elbow lock
here
not
not at this angle
not here
this way
you feel that way
do you understand
no my elbow
is going this way
with this energy
and the risk is going that way
you don't like it
and or
a wrist lock
between this hand
and this half
this hand
here
boom
they're not up to shoulder because this
hand can't assist
this way
foreign
not the shoulder
I have a grip here because I need it for
the wrist lock
and I'm going this way
[Music]
okay aside from that very common mistake
of thinking it's a shoulder pin or
laying on their back
and the reason we make that mistake is
because we're used to pushing on stuff
you know I'm gonna push on it and then I
feel my weight and I feel strong and
therefore I think I'm powerful but those
are all ego tripartite delusions okay
that's not how it goes all right the the
elbow as a joint
is
often utilized in your Aikido because
the elbow controls the wrist and the
shoulder and the other ones don't do
that so well so the elbow is a very key
control point and while it's giving you
both
um that angle of cancellation in the
other joints it controls a lot of that
person uh cross laterally as well okay
and the shoulder doesn't do that all the
time because it's a ball and socket
joint and then you have very similar
stuff on the wrist the elbow does not
have that ability
okay another very common mistake is that
as he goes up you already have in your
mind you're gonna let this thing go so
you adopt some sort of passive really
not even an angle of deflection do you
see this and then you chase this thing
on the back side and it just doesn't
happen it only happens in la la land of
a bad keyhonawanda so as it goes up
you're here
you're in the same spot okay
so your tegatana is at this angle
deflection stay there please which is
nothing more than your inner spiral stop
there carry over we go to Eco change
which side I'm forward and let me give
me nothing
here
okay that angle deflection is going to
generate
here's a kind of spillage over so I'll
just just show it with your hand you can
see this diagonal here forget what my
body's doing okay and as he slides down
it moves It Off by line
see that
so I have this diagonal here it's like a
rain gutter he goes and it misses me if
I'm here on the side and he goes down up
you understand
okay
internally this movement is to this all
the time in Temple uh it's very common
it's a instead of hitting that spot
as in your internal
in your inward spiral the tiger can hit
it this way okay uh obviously as I said
it could be an angle of deflection but
things coming down but you can also hit
with it
forearm this way okay
let's go
so when I adhere and I'm in his Center
when he pushes down it makes his whole
body go off the line you understand that
and over here stocking into it's not
going to do that this is this very
awkward position for me okay
and that angled deflection yeah
is connected here which you see again is
another inward spiral
and I'm here so the same thing as I'm
working internally as you push this down
it'll move him off the line of the cap
okay that is important because I don't
have to now go around the line of attack
without clashing with him okay
in this technique as he goes up and I
come here once I feel that that is where
I get out of the way
[Music]
do it again
he goes up I need he pushes down and I
move out of the way now if you pay
attention
watch what happens to his body in that
entire process
you see his he went that way a little do
it again
you see his name
you see that and here is the opening
go back up
put your knee perfectly straight you
could have your foot up okay it's not as
great
you see that put your knee back over
there
you can't do that on the side you can't
do that at all on the side
he's perfectly straight okay and I don't
even think you'd catch it in real life
second mistake
as you're coming around
you grab with this hand
[Music]
no
this hand
okay this head is making your same front
inward condition you always do
so if we do equal
same exact thing
boom
so he goes up boom it's right here
you're going this way
boom and around
to affect his shoulder up
boom
so many videos about Sensei doing Bay
net worth and Joe Dodie and that's all
he's doing
he's just here he's just shove it down
[Music]
okay
stop twist the shoulder in the front
Hammer because
but to that
that's going to bring his elbow onto my
rib cage
go up
not yet it's not there
but as I come around there it is
it's on my rib cage and now you have
control meaning wrist and elbow control
you see that so it's all my rib cage and
it can bring him around just like a
Gilda
so as you go up
this hand comes around bringing the
elbow to the rib cage and now it's Ikea
when your body
and if you look for the elbow you'll
never be on the shoulder
so that elbow is right here
wrist is over here
okay
[Music]
let's go back to the lock on those
he goes
okay
okay notice how my hands are closed
not far
I want to stabilize the wrist
also notice that my I'm not partly
gripping his hand or not
I have to be one side of the
articulating aspect
and on the other side
okay
so let somebody right here
some of you are here
hands are close
so when you do need you all
is here
it's not here
you're giving up leverage it's here yeah
hands close so watch
camera come around
okay
uh we'll do this
the fingers aren't in the wrist lot
because fingers are actually hinging
that way that's dumb
okay
being down by where the articulation in
is reducing your mechanical advantage
go to where the lever is longer
but not to the fingers do you understand
so you want to be at the top of the
metacarpals with all your strength
so liquid where I am
in terms of
where I can drive my power into this
it's close to my body and it's on my
Center
not over here
you see that I think this dude is strong
enough that he can open his wrist I
don't know
can you just extend your hand
[Music]
do you see I gotta be here
so that I get almost like a pushing
aspect it's the same thing truck
you understand
so your locking is very tight
tight like this
if you start coming this way there's no
way you're doing it and you don't have
the elbow either do you see that so
you're down by the elbow
the elbow is tight you feel that
pressure okay and I'm over here doing
this thing here
please note
that lock
is this lock
[Music]
does not require height
so the higher the hand goes
you're just breaking the other rule do
you see that there's no additional lock
here okay do you guys understand that so
how high should his wrist and his angle
of his arm be
that's it
don't start rocking back trying
you go this way with his elbow
this way
and into the other hand
with the wrists
okay
let's try it again okay so uh my
philosophy on locking
um is that I'm not in the law I have the
lock but I'm not in the lock so just
like if I'm I'm over here on him I'm
actually in his Center
okay do you understand that so it
doesn't change if I'm in the if I'm in
the lock I'm actually in the center
okay the lock is used as an angle
cancellation so for example uh instead
of like trying to crank them down here
which I don't even think I can but I can
move his Center okay and now the block
will be an angle cancellation so if he
tries to get up it gives me time to do
something else but that's not what took
him down do you understand
say yes okay
but when you're working your locks
I think that you should always be able
to break something
okay so this thing is on
and I should be at a mechanical
advantage externally where I can snap
that thing okay so
what that looks like of course he feels
it but you try to watch my movement as
he wants to tap
that's a sign that your lock is right on
that edge there that you can't detect
the external pressure but he can feel
like nothing's gonna go
same thing if we're here
this lock should be
at such a way
that it's already on and the same thing
I I have so much range of motion that
just kind of inhaling
will get me there as opposed to this
you see look how much I gotta go before
I even get there okay and when I'm here
stay there
and I'm here boom I have all that way to
go
from the moment I inhale there's a lot
of range of motion I have okay
same thing on this one
I should not be at such an inferior
external mechanical advantage that all I
can get is the tap
I should be in a place where I can snap
that thing slowly and surely
do you see that difference
that's as hard as I can go
[Music]
over here
boom
[Music]
okay and again how hard can I do this
boom
now my range of motion is that much
bigger with a pushy it actually just
gets stronger because it goes deeper
into the pushing cycle you understand
that
so be aware of that if you feel yourself
at your maximum effort or your maximum
range of motion
and they tap you need to tell yourself
that would have never worked in real
life
okay